truth is uh deals with truth is truth is
a feeling that goes from your gut
to your mouth instantaneously
women get to be truthful you get to say
and you say any kind of foul because you
don't have an editing it just comes up I
just two plus two is seven
just say it I don't care and you'll be
like it's it's four it ain't it's
whatever my wife
and
[Applause]
and men don't do that we can't be honest
with you man truth is cruel
if we told you the truth all the time
that's cruelty
men men go from our gut and then it
stops at the heart
where we edit it
we edit what this was what this was was
going to be foul so I'm not going to say
what this was
and then it goes into the brain for
further
touch-ups you know analysis
okay all right that sounds good and then
you say it we don't just spew stuff out
man because how we really feel about you
it's just it's not it's not cool
this how we
feel about you you said 10 years let me
ask you a question honestly what's your
Daydream on how to kill her
[Applause]
you want to get me killed
here's where you're messing up I'm gonna
tell you where you're messing up
he goes he says to me hey man you trying
to get me killed
so you see how we can tell the truth
the the LIE right that means that he
thinks about it see do you understand
what I'm saying
you should say I don't think about
killing my woman but you go you try to
get me killed if tell you how I kill
this [ __ ] she gonna kill me
so you might as well get it out now how
do you kill it man
just so she know how do you daydream
about it
spit it out she's looking at it's all
just sweetie I'm trying to let you
understand what you're dealing with I'm
just saying the fact that you're alive
means he's didn't go through with it he
just and I'm gonna tell you why why guys
think about killing their women it's
cause we love you
foreign
because I want you out of my life
what I don't want to hurt your feelings
so I'd rather you be dead
than to break your heart
so we think about how do we kill this
and
anger bro I tell you I killed my girl I
put a pill overhead
and shoot it twice with a silencer
and the feathers come up and
I look under the pillow and I still be
open and I close eye I close the eyes
and I kiss her Softly on her face but
she's dead
you might as well spit it out because
it'll help you now because it'll be you
can blame it on all the whole situation
instead of later when she's like so you
know
Puerto Rican right Cuban oh Lord have
mercy like
whatever she's whatever accent and
whatever anger she does in Spanish she's
gonna be on you so you might as well
just say it think about it
is she going to be on you what is it
what are you you know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and look at I don't condone violence
against women but I do condone thinking
about it because
sometimes it's like how do I get you out
of my face it's just like what what do
you do when a girl's in your face ah
especially black women because you know
what
this is probably more important to white
women because white women you do stuff
to get killed
people kill you your husbands kill you
black women do stuff to get hit like
they make you want to hit them because
they be in your face like they can whoop
your ass
you'd be like I'm gonna put this [ __ ]
through a fish tank
don't get in my face because I can't
even hit you
can't even poke you hard like don't
don't press me like that
what you gonna do I wish you was like oh
my God man get out of my face
and I've never hit a woman I've never
needed to and I've been been like wow
man this would be so much easier if I
could but I just you just you just like
I never even mushed a woman any woman
ever get mushed you ever get mushed
you know what a mushing is
you don't even know what mushing is do
you know what machine is
yeah see look at the black girl right
there foreign
[Applause]
it's a it's it's a it's a non-violent
movement
[Applause]
when you're in my face and it's just it
just moves you
and sometimes a twist
let's just get out of my face please
I don't know I've never done it I've
come close but I'm too scared I don't go
to jail over nonsense man jail [ __ ] I
don't do that pushing y'all don't want
to Mush a girl get out of here she
stumbled back crack ahead and you know
she's laying on the ground doing the uh
the Hulk Hogan from the 80s like
I'm like oh my God I'm lifting a hand
I'm like the referee like oh come on
[ __ ]
please get up it's just and on the third
one I'm hoping she go like this like oh
foreign
[Applause]
oh she's living
no we have these huge battles
you know what the matter she ever got of
me was one time she was watching this
show was like a poor excuse for the view
and they started talking about domestic
violence right for the 9 millionth time
this year they're talking about domestic
violence just in case you know you
didn't get the memo you know evidently
you know just some people didn't get it
it's not okay to slam your wife's head
into the cupboard drawers
because she didn't dry the can opener
off properly you know
it's gonna [ __ ] rust right
how do you not know not to do that [ __ ]
do they really have to keep talking
about it who it's like wife beaters
watching oh [ __ ] ah now I get it up so
Daisy sweetheart here we go there you go
oh
[Applause]
so at the end of the hour they come to
The Logical conclusion they're like
there is no reason to hit a woman there
is no reason to hit a woman
and I was just like really I could give
you like 17 right off the top of my head
you can wake me from a drunken stupor I
could still give you like nine
dude there's plenty of reasons to hit a
woman you just don't do it
but to sit there and suggest that
there's no reason
no the level of ego behind that
statement what are you levitating above
the rest of us you're never annoying
wait a minute how many times have you
thought about slapping your your [ __ ]
guy in the head this week
there you go
every day
you didn't do it right
oh dude it drives me nuts there's no
reason there's no reason really no
reason how about this you marry a girl
you fall in love you buy her house you
go to work every day paying off the
house you come home one day she's
banging the next door neighbor hands you
divorce papers you gotta move out sleep
on a futon and still pay for that house
that she's gonna stay in no reason
I'm not saying you should do it but
there's plenty of [ __ ] reasons in
that Arc of a story
all right that was a hypothetical
you want an actual story
I'll give you one I'll give you one all
right I [ __ ] up my foot playing drums
trying to get my bass drum foot as fast
as uh John Bonhams because I figure
that's a good thing to focus on 43 years
of age never married no kids I figured
this this is going to lead me to the
light right this this is what I need to
do
so I don't know what I did I I felt like
I have to I played for like an hour and
afterwards I felt like it literally like
there was some [ __ ] stabbing me in the
bottom of my foot right like I had
lightning coming out of the bottom of my
foot
so I did the typical guy thing like I'm
not going to the hospital I'll sleep it
off be fine right next morning I wake up
my foot's even worse and I gotta walk my
crazy dog
so I'm like I can't do it my foot's
killing me so I wake up my girl go
sweetheart Sweden can do me a favor can
you do me a favor can you walk the dog
for me can you uh just take the shift
you know I'll do your afternoon shift
can you just do me the song you can do
this for me and she's just like oh
you know I had a late night last night
I'm tired I have a big day and I just go
[ __ ] it
she goes what do you mean [ __ ] it it's
like why can't you just say no why do
you always gotta like waterboard me with
like a 20 minute explanation that
eventually lines its way around to go
[ __ ] yourself just say no
so I'm just limping out of the room what
happened go back to bed you got a big
day right
so now I'm like limping down the street
I got like Tourette's [ __ ] God damn
[ __ ] dogs walking next to me
foreign
I gotta admit I got a little childish
I did I got a little childish you know I
was just thinking about my relationship
and like this is the relationship I'm in
you're just gonna do whatever the hell
you want to do right and [ __ ] me fine
I'm gonna do whatever the hell I want to
do I feel like listening to my iPod on
full blast walking around the house
that's what I'm gonna do
so that's what I did turned it all the
way up and I just my whole plan was just
to walk by her like I didn't even know
her that was it she came down the hall I
just ghosted her just walked right past
her
just trying to piss her off and I got to
tell you something worked like a charm
work like a charm
yeah hung my coat up turned around by
the time I turned around she was already
yelling at me but the music was so loud
not only could I not hear her it
actually looked like she was singing the
song that I was listening to
it's one of the highlights of the
relationship
so I knew what she was saying it was
like whatever I don't want to talk about
it leave me alone I'm going on to the
computer right so I limp over and I sit
down and unbeknownst to me she's like
now we're going to talk about this right
now comes out poo and slaps the
headphones off my head I got a big I got
big ears it [ __ ] hurt
so I'm like honey leave me alone I don't
want to talk about it put the headphones
back on she comes right back up again
poo slaps them off a little harder this
time they spin Halfway Around My Head
caveman DNA starts coming up talking
through my teeth honey leave me alone
don't want to talk about it right put
him on third time she comes out who
slaps him right across the room and I
snap I'm like fine you want to have the
fight let's [ __ ] have the fight she's
like we will discuss this later when you
calm down
[Applause]
thirsty come on let me out of here I
have a spin class you've made your point
this is this is ridiculous
no that's the thing
really is that's the thing I hate that
saying there's no reason obviously I'm
not saying to hit a woman you know
but saying there's no reason I think
that's crazy
when you say there's no reason that
kills any sort of examination as to how
two people ended up at that at that
place you say there's no reason you cut
out the build up you just left with the
ACT how are you going to solve it if you
don't figure it out
look how awkward it is in here right now
I said you shouldn't hit a woman I'm
just saying how come you can't ask
questions you can only ask questions
about what the guy did you can never ask
about the woman why is that
why is that what is that
what is what does answer them right mean
what does that mean are you the idiot
who got up halfway through the special
during the bit and you're like walking
around like I'm not [ __ ] taping a
special here what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you
[ __ ] had to ignore all of that and
now you're gonna like yell out and not
only that yells something that makes no
[ __ ] sense whatsoever
answer him answer him
every [ __ ] special I do there's
always one
he's right down the [ __ ] middle
[Applause]
talking about hitting women sweetheart
and I think you just added another
reason
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
I love this I'm not even in a
relationship with her and she's [ __ ]
nagging me
I believe look
[Applause]
I understand hitting a woman is a bad
thing okay well yeah how come you can't
[ __ ] ask questions I just don't
understand like if I get bit by a
rattlesnake wouldn't you guys have some
questions
right how did it happen did you not see
it were you [ __ ] with it
how did this snake get so mad it almost
killed you
firemen put out a fire they don't just
drive away afterwards they sift through
the debris
how did it start here's an oily rag
right
look I realize I'm coming off pretty
ignorant right about now
I realize that
let me extend an olive branch then okay
I realize that there's some animal guys
out there okay horrible guys you know
have a rough day at the factory come
home tuner casserole and just start
swinging all right
I'm not trying to say that those people
don't exist I realize they exist they
should be buried underneath the prison
okay
so if I can admit that ladies can you at
least admit that every ass kicking
doesn't just fall out of the [ __ ] sky
really
even hockey has two minutes for
instigating right
Stan that's some back and forth happened
before that [ __ ] you know
you know what it is it's every case is
handled like that Rihanna one well they
just say the guy's a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
this guy blah blah sent him a jail and
then they never ask anything about that
you know I'm not saying he should have
done it but I'm just saying
I'm just saying dude in your heart of
hearts
what do you think was going down before
that happened you think she was just
sitting there going oh my God Baskin
Robbins you want to get some ice cream
you know
what do you think maybe they were having
some epic end of the relationship fight
and some crazy [ __ ] was being said maybe
she was screaming in his ears some crazy
female [ __ ] like oh [ __ ] all your
friends I don't give a [ __ ]
maybe that's why I sell my albums in you
[ __ ]
right
to be fair she could have just been
sitting there going I need a tissue do
you keep those in the glove box oh my
God I'll bring my
oh [ __ ] that because you know what it is
they never address how women argue which
I think is the core of a lot of that
[ __ ]
you know and I got to tell you something
man like I never knew how women argued
but after 20 years of losing every
significant battle
in a relationship I finally figured out
how they argued I might tell you
something I'm starting to turn this
franchise around
all right
I have begun a winning tradition
this is how they argue as far as I can
tell all right if they're right they
argue the point and they stay on point
and make sure you stay on point until
you're down on your knees apologizing
begging for forgiveness all right no
problem with that totally respected but
here's the thing if they're wrong they
go Rogue they go off-road they start
thinking of [ __ ] you're sensitive about
maybe you don't get along with your dad
and in their head they just start
concocting this evil statement
totally designed this desperate Hail
Mary attempt to make you so [ __ ] mad
you just call him a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] trumps all the [ __ ] they
did to start the argument now it's not
about that one that's no reason to call
me a [ __ ] and then that's it you're in
this room now right
my girl knows my big thing is my big
fear in life is to be that dude who
grows old you know grows old alone has
like that basement apartment just
screaming up at the younger couple turn
it down
that isn't music
so I noticed that anytime she was losing
a fight I don't know why she just feels
but that's why he's just gonna grow old
and be alone
all of my [ __ ]
in the kitchen washing dishes for the
ninth [ __ ] time in a row this is what
the argument was about I was so right
what happened
so if you learn anything from my
ignorance tonight
just know this next time you're in a
battle with your beautiful woman your
wife girlfriend whatever and they start
out of nowhere okay you're winning and
they just start saying that crazy [ __ ]
out of nowhere just know in that moment
you've won the fight okay
all right don't get mad Bob and weave
slip all of that [ __ ] maybe because you
got a little dick just let that slide
stay in the pocket of the argument
okay it's over the argument is over
You've Won just take a knee and run out
the clock all right
yes lean on the ropes let them punch
themselves out and then in the end you
throw this psychology right back at him
well maybe we should discuss it later
would you calm down
and they won't hook up with you for a
couple of days who cares who cares you
rub one out
rub one out like a man it's a champagne
of victory
[Applause]